we start with some breaking news and in
the last few minutes President Putin has
appeared to indicate that he may be
ready to talk about reaching agreements
over the war in Ukraine well with me now
has retired Air Vice martial Sean Bell
and Sean this could certainly be game
changing it could be but I think we've
got to be very very careful about
jumping to conclusions here there's the
first information that Russia might be
willing to start talking
um if you look at this from a grand
strategic perspective over the last
month we've heard the German Chancellor
Schultz talk about the potential for
talking we've talked about heard
president mackerel talk about the
potential for Russia and the whole idea
about NATO expansion we've heard about
Biden President Biden talk about talking
and now we're hearing the just the
potential for Russia to be involved I'm
pretty sure at this stage that Putin
would desperately want to pause in the
fighting his army is battered he's
running out of supplies he's on the back
foot and winter is not being kind to the
the battles on the battlefield but from
president perspective I cannot see for a
moment that he's going to be in any
position to negotiate at all I think
we've got to be really careful here I
think on the spectrum of there's no
chance of negotiation to ultimately this
will end with a negotiated settlement
we're looking for a binary answer all
we're hearing at the moment is maybe
we're seeing a slight nudge towards the
day when potentially talking might start
and it'll be sometime after that when
we'll get any form of negotiated
solution and Sean we've also had that
sort of stop-start attitude throughout
this war Putin says one thing one minute
and it actually restarts once he's
gained a little bit of power and
ammunition could we see something like
this happening or could we actually get
to a stage where we see an end to this
war completely at some stage that's a
very very easy question I think one of
the things we we do know is that um
regularly we report on what Putin says
and actually what he says has got
nothing to do with what's actually
happening on the ground part of the
background to this state statement was
he was talking about the Minsk agreement
which was an agreement in 2014-15 around
the donbass region that was brokered as
a bit of a peace thing and lamenting
that that was not followed would you
actually go back to 1994 The Budapest
memo when Russia America and Ukraine
signed up to Ukraine giving up nuclear
weapons and Russia said it would
absolutely respect the borders Russia's
actually walked away from that so I
think we've again got to be really
careful Putin picks his moments for a
domestic audience sometimes sometimes an
international audience I think we've got
a long way to go yet before we're
anywhere close to having a negotiated
settlement